les faits remontent au 5 janvier 2019 en
plein acte 8 du mouvement des gelées
jaune christophe dettinger un ancien
boxeur professionnel assène plusieurs
coups un gendarme mobile
à l'époque une cagnotte est lancée sur
internet en quelques jours elle atteint
les 140 5000 euros leetchi avait
toutefois décidé le 8 janvier de
suspendre cette cagnotte qui avait fait
l'objet de critiques de syndicats de
policiers et de certains responsables
politiques au mois de décembre dernier
c'est l'avocate de christophe dettinger
qui monte au créneau
elle demande que son client récupère la
totalité de la somme versée en ligne + 2
millions d'euros au titre de dommages et
intérêts de son côté litchi ton
d'expliquer le blocage de cette cagnotte
par un bug informatique et un montant
atteint suffisant pour l'objectif
initial litchi s'engage à ce que les
fonds collectés sur la cagnotte de
soutien à christophe dettinger servent
uniquement à financer les frais de
justice conformément à nos conditions
générales d'utilisation à la législation
en vigueur permettre non à christophe
dettinger de récupérer cet argent
le tribunal de paris va donc rendre son
verdict aujourd'hui
une décision des juges pour enfin savoir
qui l'emportera au point
[Musique]